[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
hello everybody
[Music]
you are the bravest people in san
francisco apparently can i take a
picture of my first live audience in 20
months
wave everyone
hey
all right
well as you might imagine
when we planned this
we're in a different space uh so thank
you all for coming um i'm gonna
we'll start the night um as we used to
at all of our live events with what we
call a long short
and uh it's a short film about long-term
thinking and this one um is unbelievably
apropos for the moment that we're in
enjoy
[Music]
if you are at first really [ __ ]
anxious
just wait
it'll get worse
and then you'll get the hang of it
maybe
start with the reasonable feelings
discomfort lack of focus the sadness of
alone
you can try to do yoga you can shut off
the radio when it gets to you you can
message your family or your friends or
your colleagues you're not supposed to
leave your home anyway so it's safe for
you
there's also the gym
you can't go there but you could pretend
to you could get bendy by yourself in
your bedroom
and there's public transportation
probably best to avoid it but there's
prayer and meditation yes always employ
it
if you have pains in your chest because
your anxiety won't rest take a moment
take a breath
start simple
things you can handle based on your
interests your issues and your triggers
and your inner logistics
i miss lunch counters so much i've been
eating sandwiches and pickles while
hanging unabashedly with my phone
when you're tired again of still being
alone make yourself a dinner
but don't invite anybody over
put something green in it or maybe
orange chips are fine sometimes but they
won't keep you charged feed your heart
if people are your nourishment i get you
feel the feelings that undo you while
you have to keep apart
watch a movie in the dark and pretend
someone is with you
watch all the credits because you have
time and not much else to do or watch
all of the credits to remember how many
people come together just to tell a
story just to make a picture of
and then set yourself up dancing like
it's a club where everybody knows you
and they're all gonna hold you all night
long they're gonna dance around you and
with you and on their own it's your
favorite song with the hardest face and
the cathartic drums your heart pumps
hard you be long you put your hands up
to feel it
with the come down comes the weeping
those downward eyes and feelings
the truth is you can't go dancing not
right now
not at any club or party in any
town the heartbreak of this astounds you
it joins all lakes way down and you can
visit them but please don't stay there
go outside if you're able
breathe air
there are trees for hugging don't be
embarrassed
it's your friend it's your mother it's
your new crush lay your cheek against
the bark it's a living thing to touch
sadly leave all benches empty
appreciate the kindness and the distance
of strangers as you pine for company and
wave at your neighbors save for the
deaths of your conversations the layers
uncovered in this strange space and time
society is afraid of change and no one
wants to die
not now from a tiny virus not later from
the world on fire
but death is a truth we all hate to know
we all get to live and then we all have
to go
in the meantime we're surrounded we're
alone
each a thread woven in the fabric
unraveling in moments though each solo
entity spinning on its axis forgetting
that the galaxy includes us all
hearing our faults
from grace from each other from god
whatever doesn't matter the disaster is
that we believe we're separate or not
as evidenced by viruses taking down
societies as proven by the loneliness
inherent in no gathering
as palpable as a vacancy in the space of
one person hugging
if this disruption undoes you
if the absence of people unravels you
if touched was the tether that held you
together and now that it severed you're
fragile too
lean into loneliness and know you're not
alone in it
lean into loneliness like it is holding
you
like it is a generous representative of
a glaring truth
oh we are connected we forget this
yet we always knew
[Music]
yeah it feels painfully real doesn't it
um
as i mentioned i'm alexander rose the
executive director here at long now and
um
i am a infrastructure nerd um everywhere
i every where i travel all my pictures
are of infrastructure
and not people and so i started
following both of our speakers tonight a
long time ago
and
we've had each of them separately for
talks at the interval over the years and
and i remember when we had the last one
with uh with nicola uh i asked her what
was the project that she's working on
next and she said oh well i've been
working on this book about the
the the coming quarantine for several
years with jeff and uh
and it it sounded intriguing um and all
of a sudden of course we found ourselves
in quarantine
and so it was uh
seemed like the perfect talk to come
back to um for all of you and so they
have been doing this research for um
many many years over i think you said
started the project back in 2015
and um are now it was going to be about
the coming quarantine and is now about
the history and the future of quarantine
so welcome
jeff mano and nicola truly
[Applause]
cool thank you
for the introduction xander and uh
thanks to everybody for coming out
um as xander mentioned you know we
you're we're certainly the bravest
people in san francisco uh so you should
be proud of making it out to to an
in-person event
and uh thanks for taking on the the risk
of hearing about quarantine
uh while the world still teeters on the
edge of various lockdowns
so what we wanted to do tonight um is
nikki and i would be presenting just
some of the themes from the book until
proven safe
uh what we're not gonna do is give sort
of an exhaustive through survey of
everything that's in the book every
single theme
it's a book that covers uh you know more
than 600 years of quarantine going back
to its origins we look at quarantine
across species uh even uh
quarantine-like behaviors that exist in
the animal kingdom and with insects
we look at quarantine in the food supply
and in agriculture
we we look at it at various scales both
in time and space and what we wanted to
do was actually just choose some of the
themes and some of the sites that we
visited and some of the people that we
met
that would we thought would fit along
now audience and bring those to you
tonight so
anything that we don't discuss
explicitly during the talk itself um i
believe you have these little cards that
you can write questions down on
so if there's something that you want to
come back to whether it's insect
quarantine or whatever it might be
feel free to do to do so
so uh the important the most important
thing i'd say with uh any kind of
conversation about quarantine um is just
making sure that we know what we're
talking about from a vocabulary point of
view that we're using the right
definitions and and and thus the correct
words
um as is uh still the case uh even in
the medical community um the words
isolation and quarantine are very often
used interchangeably um you know um like
i say even sometimes medical
professionals will do this certainly in
the vernacular uh you know if
if you test positive and you stay home
you might say that you're quarantining
um but in reality uh there's a there's a
very key difference between these and
there's a big difference for why we
wrote a book about quarantine not a book
about isolation
um so isolation and brief means that you
know you're infected medical isolation
you know you have a disease you know
that something is dangerous it's been
diagnosed as such and you're keeping it
spatially or temporally separate from
you and it's in a state of isolation um
so for example when president trump
uh tested positive for kovid and then
and then tweeted that he was undergoing
a quarantine process uh in true trumpian
fashion that was the wrong use of the
word he was actually undergoing an
isolation process
but in any case quarantine then and the
reason why we were really drawn to it a
quarantine requires uncertainty uh
quarantine means you do not know if you
have an infection um you don't know if
you have a disease you don't know if
this this thing approaching you is
infected or contaminated it might be an
object or an animal or a relative
but the whole point is that you are
unsure of whether or not this this thing
this person this entity um will be a
risk to you and quarantine is the act of
keeping yourself separate from it to see
if that threat emerges from within and
so when looked at that way quarantine
immediately turns into a really
interesting series of metaphors
it becomes the possibility that we all
have something monstrous lurking within
ourselves but we have to give it the
space and time to be revealed
it turns into something where uh it's
not just metaphoric but even has
religious overtones or theological
overtones um and that's something that
is actually uh augmented or emphasized
even by the the the word quarantine
itself which comes from uh the old
venetian dialect for quarantina which
means 40 quarants of journey is 40 days
quarantine is supposed to be a 40-day
process
40 was not chosen numerically for
medical purposes
in fact originally quarantine was 30
days it was a trentine
trentina
but 40 was a way of tying this
experience back to uh
biblical notions of you know christ's
alleged 40 days and 40 nights in the
desert the 40 days of lent the 40 days
and 40 nights of rain that uh that we
encounter in the story of noah's ark uh
even the the uh 40 as a just sort of a
general number that means uh is
approximately the length of a generation
in in in hebrew culture
and so
40 then ties quarantine back to this
sort of religious metaphoric sense that
was something that was really exciting
that we wanted to explore with the book
but then fundamentally i'd say
and to throw things over to nikki i'd
say that quarantine is really about it's
a way that we model the unknown and we
often do that through a lens
or a filter of fear and quarantine is is
how we give shape to the the period of
encountering it
yes so because as jeff says
when someone is being quarantined they
are not a certain danger we merely
suspect that they might pose a risk um
you get into the question of risk
perception and as we all know risk
perception is subject to bias whether
unconscious or otherwise and this is why
you know quarantine despite being one of
our most proven effective tools in
reducing the spread of disease and in in
extremely powerful and necessary
also has an extremely long history of
abuse um
it's also a very dangerous and powerful
tool it's one of the few instances in a
in today's world where you are an
anglo-saxon legal thought for example
where you are essentially guilty until
proven innocent you are contagious until
proven safe
um and so that the ethnic scapegoating
that we saw
um during covet 19 when asian americans
are being targeted as sort of perceived
disease vectors that has a long history
so just to give a local example
here in san francisco 120 years ago um
at the time a local
elites wished to redevelop the area that
is chinatown raise it and redevelop it
prime piece of real estate and so when
a chinese lumber salesman was
found to have the plague that was a
perfect excuse and they locked down the
entire neighborhood behind fence posts
and barbed wire
but
the um
the uh this heavily guarded sort of
cordon sanitaire
zigzagged around white owned businesses
so it was the most gerrymandered
quarantine ever ever and that actually
proved its downfall um a judge sort of
noted that
it was obviously targeted not by disease
exposure risk but by ethnicity and that
was
that was enough to knock it down most
victims of quarantine who've been you
know
subject to this power's abuse have not
been so lucky in the book we tell the
story of the american plan
which is the largest recent mass
quarantine that most americans have
never heard of um it started in 1917 and
under its powers uh tens of thousands of
so-called loose women
were detained on suspicion of spreading
venereal disease um
and there was no legal recourse for them
um so this is something to bear in mind
with quarantine a long history that
something that is fundamentally based on
uncertainty and suspicion
risks um then giving a scientific
endorsement to existing biases
um and and our existing perceived
monsters as it were
um and so a great example i think of
just how foundational quarantine and
isolation and the logics of separation
are to
[Music]
the mythology in particular here of the
west
is the story of alexander's gates this
is something that we describe in the
book
the legend of alexander's gates are that
alexander the great the conqueror
allegedly whilst leading his army
through the caucasus region of central
asia
had his workers construct and weld
together huge iron gates
these gates would stand in the in a
mountain pass somewhere in the caucasus
and would hold at bay a kind of
monstrous eastern other
uh thus being the caucasus mountains
helping to literally define the western
the the caucasian west against this kind
of seething world of deformity and and
and uh uh you know uh
incoming monstrosity um and so actually
the myth was taken so seriously at the
time even though it's just a folklore
it's sorry it's a folktale um that
actually maps of the time
often feature uh a a band of iron and
and one and certain parts of the map
that were meant to represent at this
this this idea of alexander's gates kind
of holding the the east at bay
um there's an interesting individual um
steven asthma who wrote a book that
looks at uh monsters and how they're
figured in western mythology what it
means when we come up with a new monster
what that monster represents how we
crystallized a certain series of fears
into that
figure
and he writes about alexander's gates
and it's quite interesting that
as is the case with many of the stories
of quarantine including some that we'll
talk about this evening
often quarantine fails because of some
very very small vulnerability some minor
event or some minor actor or character
who
comes into the picture and and makes the
entire scheme fall apart
in this case it's quote unquote a lowly
fox
a fox actually uh being a curious uh
animal um digs through from the western
side under the gates and into the
monster zone as asthma calls it um the
monsters are kind of you know shocked
and surprised to see a fox and follow it
back into the western world
uh and this is what asma calls the the
realm of the reprobate is is unleashed
upon the west um but this is just a new
version or rather a different version of
the doomsday myth that when these gates
that you know keep our world separate
from the world of monsters falls apart
um you know we become a victim of the
things that we've been trying to hold
separate from us for for in this case
you know
thousands of years
so
today the uh the frontier beyond which
there may be monsters and through which
our curiosity will sort of breed create
a breach is uh is
space
um the
and that brings us to planetary
quarantine which is something we explore
in the book um
when in the 1950s it first became sort
of clear that rockets were actually
sufficiently advanced that we were
maybe going to get to space
people started to worry what will happen
when alien biospheres collide we had an
example of that when the old world
europeans
colonized the new world and that did not
work out so well for at least one side
of that biosphere and there was a sense
that we needed to you know explore this
new cosmic frontier a little more
responsibly um
one microbiologist from stanford
actually sort of said look we're in a
better position than columbus was to
have our cake and eat it too here
so um
planetary protection became planetary
planetary quarantine became the
planetary protection which became
uh international law and uh it
encompasses two different strands so one
is forward contamination that's bringing
earth life um to extraterrestrial
environments and a couple of reasons for
this one earth life might wipe out alien
life and also it might just make it
really hard to know if we found alien
life for bringing life with us um so
forward contamination is you know
why i am dressed in this bunny suit
having gone through rigorous de
contamination procedures and been very
carefully instructed on what shampoo to
use and what condition my nails should
be in
um when visiting uh the
perseverance the rover that's now on
mars
there's also back contamination and that
is when um we are bringing
either
samples or people back from
extraterrestrial environments now this
became an issue during the apollo
missions
um
and so it involved the cdc sort of
officially said hey you're not bringing
the astronauts back unless they go into
quarantine and nasa said oh well we
didn't think there was life on the moon
so we weren't planning that and had to
scramble um so they retrofitted an
airstream trailer
put the astronauts and the lunar samples
in it
brought them back to
houston where they had constructed the
lunar receiving lab essentially a
quarantine facility
and
and then they
declared a federal quarantine
there to prevent the risk of
contaminating earth with
extraterrestrial life which is the only
time there's been a quarantine against
extraterrestrial life in the federal
register
and then um
and and then you know
eventually realized there was no need
for that there was no life on the moon
but what's interesting about this is you
know if if quarantine is about
uncertainty um and
then planetary quarantine is sort of a
fractal example of uncertainty we have
no idea
if there is life elsewhere in the
universe and if so if it poses the
danger to earth life we have no idea if
earth life would pose a danger to it or
even if earth life would be capable of
replicating in extraterrestrial
environments so what do you do when
you're trying to
minimize risk with no data and yet
kind of existential sakes
um at the the start um
of planetary quarantine it was sort of a
uh actuarial fantasy where scientists
decided that there should be no more
than a one in a thousand chance of
seeding an alien planet with earth life
and then every mission used up some
imaginary fraction of that total
imaginary number
these days
in our new era of mars sample return and
private space exploration we've moved on
to a list that it's sort of a category
system that may be familiar if you're if
you're up on like for example the uk's
covid requirements in red red list
countries and amber plus and so on
um and there is as with the uk's covet
list a similar lack of enforcement
and as with we as we saw with kovid
there is a similar set of arguments
where some scientists say this is
complete overkill it's holding back
progress and others say it's
insufficient it's not protecting us
you're putting it at risk
um
just like covet
um so one of the things that we did with
the book uh was
uh look into the life of a man named
john howard he was an 18th century
british prison reformer
who looked at architecture as really a
way to
pursue humanitarian
uh aid to uh to increase the um the
comfort
of the incarcerated by uh traveling
around europe by visiting prisons
dungeons and jails um seeing how people
were kept and in the process uh
advocating for the reform of those of
those institutions of those buildings
and of the treatment of prisoners in a
more humane manner however he also
noticed that quarantine facilities were
very similar to these prisons and jails
people were treated in a very similar
manner they were often kept in very very
similar buildings sometimes the same
building and so at the end of john
howard's life he went on a new mission
around europe uh ended up as far east as
russia
what is now ukraine in fact and
devoted the the his 60s to reforming
quarantine uh to visiting lazarettos and
quarantine facilities um and so there's
one chapter in our book in particular
where we follow in john howard's
footsteps but what we wanted to really
do throughout the book was ask you know
where would a 21st century john howard
someone who was investigating sites of
quarantine who wanted to see where
quarantine was being experimented with
or the technical limits of isolation
were being pushed today where would such
a person go
and so there are many many places in the
book that would be answers to that
question but one of the more outrageous
responses and one of the more extreme
sites that i that someone interested in
quarantine or isolation could go to
today
is what you see on the screen
right now
this is down in a salt mine known as the
waste isolation pilot plant it's outside
carlsbad new mexico it's near the border
with texas
in fact if you're familiar with the
guadalupe mountains
it's actually down in texas it's part of
the same
old reef system uh of an inland sea that
has long since obviously disappeared and
it's that same inland sea that created
the guadalupe mountain reef
that also
left behind these gigantic salt deposits
that are now 2150 feet below the earth
beneath the earth's surface and that's
where whip has been constructed
and so very very quickly especially
because i started off talking about the
the definitions of isolation and
quarantine it is the waste isolation
pilot plant so to be clear it's not a
quarantine facility for nuclear waste
which i'll get to in a second it's an
isolation facility and on top of that
it's a pilot plant so it's a it's an
experimental facility
but so this is where nuclear waste is
being buried by the us government
it's not the kind of nuclear waste that
you might picture and certainly at least
speaking for myself that i pictured and
you'll see a photograph later of what it
looked like um but it's nuclear waste in
the sense of
fabrics and gowns and gloves and
scientific equipment like microscopes
desks pens papers
that were used by scientists
in laboratories where they were
developing the nation's nuclear arsenal
and so those materials that may may or
may not be contaminated but also you
know
do pose a risk to the biosphere
are being shipped to new mexico they're
being put into giant caskets and then
they're being lowered into the depths of
the earth as i mentioned 2150 feet into
these huge salt deposits
you can see in the schematic diagram
that as you go down the shaft
over to the right of the things that
kind of almost look like grids
those are the drifts and then the panels
and then the rooms um the rooms are
our individual rooms are huge you know
the room itself is very roughly the size
of a let's just say a tennis court
and then there's 56 of those rooms
throughout these panels so when you go
down into the depths and drive around
through the salt
you know you can often enter into uh
hallways where it's difficult even
necessarily to see the very end of it
but so there are several interesting
things here um one is that the salt is
actually a kind of a plastic mineral
what i mean by that is that when you
apply enough pressure to it salt moves
like almost like a marshmallow
or was described to us as molasses in
january
and so when you look closely and you can
see it a little bit in this photograph
the salt is actually crushing its way
back into these into these uh corridors
and rooms but that's by design so salt
is not only resistant to radiation and
can block it so it's already a shield
against these the radioisotopes that are
being emitted uh from the uh from the
waste or or should there be an accident
um but also the whole point is that once
humans abandon this architectural
structure and uh no longer go down into
it the salt will just continue to crush
it'll squeeze in and
basically form a kind of crystalline
tomb for all of the things that are
buried within it and so as you drive
through you can see these kind of rock
nets that are all um uh you know
collapsing on top
and then coming down
um but so our guide to this actually was
a fascinating individual guy named
abraham van luck who was a department of
energy geophysicist but also in his
spare time uh was uh very interested in
catholic mysticism and specifically
dante
and had been writing had his own blog
that was looking at the the divine
comedy looking at the role of
transcendental love
and he was our guide to this to this
underworld facility in new mexico
he was very careful to keep those two
parts of his personality safe we we kind
of joked that one part was quarantined
from the other um and so as we drove
around or as we spoke about whip you
know he was very careful to to keep keep
us on the topic of geotechnical
engineering not on dante or the inferno
but nevertheless these kinds of things
really kind of seep into the nuclear
waste community um one thing that that
you'll notice right away when you start
researching this is that underworld
metaphors in fact can be found
throughout the nuclear waste industry
so
you know castor and pollux are the name
of two
types of containers used by the european
waste
management companies
eurydice is incredibly an acronym but
it's also the name of a european waste
consortium that helps deal with some of
these engineering issues
etc etc you can find these kinds of
things throughout throughout the the the
the the industry
um but this actually kind of came to a
head with some uh experiments actually
i'm gonna go back that was that was the
nuclear waste i i gave you a little a
little spoiler um but um there there's a
a project
uh that really caught our attention
because it was something that we found
throughout the history of quarantine
which was how do you communicate risk to
individuals and to people and how do
they believe what you're saying so if
you're trying to convince people
thousands of generations from now
and you're dealing with nuclear waste
that's going to be dangerous for at
least 10 000 and possibly many millions
of years how do you convince them that
this is in fact a dangerous substance
that they should not in fact dig it up
and that it's something to be avoided
you know we saw even during covet 19
that people didn't believe that covet
and still don't believe that it's a real
disease um that think that the cure is
act the vaccine rather
is actually a bio weapon you know there
are people that don't uh if you're not
if you don't trust the information
that's coming to you why on earth would
you trust some sign that you found that
was written 8 000 years ago and it's in
the middle of the desert telling you not
to dig
so that may sound like a very niche
thing to be concerned about but in fact
there's a lot of real worry that that
whip is going to be disinterred and so
beginning in the 1980s there was a
series of department of energy funded
roundtables that looked at bringing
together semioticians anthropologists
linguists experts in religion
even experts in radiation sickness and
brought them all together to kind of
brainstorm what we could do to prepare
future generations uh to to to believe
the message of of danger
i won't go into too many specifics um
although it is a fascinating field just
to give a sense of what they came up
with
you know some is kind of titanic land
art there's one that's a giant landscape
of thorns where made of concrete the
idea apparently being that aggressive
geometric shapes almost like that
fountain
down near the embarcadero near the near
the ferry building you know aggressive
geometric shapes would be just so
terrifying that people will leave and
they won't they would never consider
digging there
another one one of my personal favorites
was a was a i guess the department of
energy in the 1980s was so uh
sensitive to the site of edvard monk's
famous painting the scream um if you've
ever seen home alone the macaulay culkin
film it's what he's doing on the in the
poster
but that was considered so terrifying in
the 1980s apparently that edvard amongst
the screen was going to be reproduced at
various scales throughout the website in
order to scare future generations from
digging there
um another one
it was the raycat proposal which was
actually to make cats genetically modify
domestic house cats so that if cats came
into the region and there was there was
loose radiation
and then radionuclides in the in the in
the environment the cats would change
color and potentially even emit
fluorescent light
and somehow uh people with these cats
would conclude from that that there must
be a leaking underground radio a
radiation source and they'll leave the
the the greater carlsbad area and and go
to where their cats no longer glow
and one of the worst ideas though
actually came from a nuclear waste
conference that we went to in 2016
for my birthday actually which was a
fascinating place to be um but where
they
a current a then current employee of the
department of energy said with a
straight face that the actual solution
was what he was working on which was a
an exceptionally detailed legacy website
it would be accessible by smartphone
and you could you could find schematics
and diagrams and everything just warning
you about what was down in the in the
depths the mineral depths of whip but
the idea of course that smartphones let
alone wi-fi let alone even the internet
itself won't be around tens of thousands
of years from now um didn't really seem
to be
of concern of this individual
um but so in any case i've gone on too
long so i'll just do a couple more
details here but so this is the waste
face um this is nuclear waste um it's
inside these canisters often just with
saran wrap and barrels
it was quite anticlimactic even though
we were given dosimeters to register if
we were being exposed to radiation i
think you know again speaking for myself
i was expecting something you know a
glowing green mass in the depths of the
earth in fact it looked like they were
kind of loading up a transatlantic
flight
um but so
what was so
interesting i think about this entire
experience and came out of even seeing
the waste face and realizing that what
appears to be dangerous uh or what
doesn't look dangerous at all might in
fact be exceptionally dangerous um
really kind of came when we started
looking into what are the risks of of of
nuclear waste and and its burial in
certain sites in the united states it's
isolation or as it were it's metaphoric
quarantine
um and so there was one paper in
particular that we were drawn to that
looked at the logistic chain uh the
quarantine logistics chain that brings
nuclear waste to places like whip or
another facility that is now temporarily
at least uh off the off the uh the death
or is not going to happen anymore called
yucca mountain in nevada
where that would actually be the really
serious high-level nuclear waste fuel
rods things like that
um so in any case they calculated that
if there were a
the waste going to yucca mountain would
go through las vegas incredibly and they
calculated that if there was a high
speed collision either on the the
highway or using the trains that were
carrying this waste um you know what
would actually what are the stakes of
that how how scared should we be
um and what this paper found and what
was quite extraordinary was that um you
know this stuff would
obviously release a radioactive plume um
it would affect hundreds of thousands of
people within minutes um within 91.3
seconds um local casinos and hotels and
convention centers would have their hvic
systems overwhelmed by radiation coming
from the desert from the accident site
and they looked into things like you
know if you turn off the hvac but don't
do it in time
etc etc you know these radionuclides can
get locked into the carpets and the
roulette tables and all of the furniture
and kind of irradiate the buildings from
within
um so to make a long story short though
they came to the conclusion that
an accident like that could be so bad
that um the machines used to clean it up
could take 25 000 machine years
that the city itself
may have to be raised depending on how
you feel about las vegas you know it
would may
temper your reaction to this or las
vegas itself might have to just be
entirely abandoned to the sands um in a
kind of what they call permanent
quarantine
but so in other words the risks are very
you know maybe low that that's going to
actually happen but the consequences are
very high
um and so i'll just end then with the
idea that you know we we've built this
unbelievable kind of zero risk
architecture with whip the whole point
of whip is that we can take something a
glove that may or may not have traces of
plutonium on it we can take that from a
site somewhere else in the united states
bring it all the way to new mexico and
bury it
ostensibly for eternity
um but so to do all of that with
billions of dollars in spence it was a
100 000 page environmental application
in order to get whip constructed um it
was thus like the lowly fox that brings
down alexander's gates um it was
eye-opening and sobering to realize that
or to hear rather that in 2014
kitty litter almost undid the entire
thing so there was an explosion and a
barrel
erupted down in the depths of whip and
released radiation throughout its own
little panel
and so much so that it caused 500
million dollars worth of damage
parts of whip can no longer be used for
their function which ironically is to
bury nuclear waste but it's considered
too dangerous to go into them and
they've been sealed off
and radionuclides actually were vented
beyond the site
but the guy who figured out what happens
realized that someone had packed
these barrels using the wrong kind of
kitty litter they'd used organic kitty
litter which is based as a wheat based
absorbent it sounds really good it's
organic
but normally it would be a clay-based
absorbent which can help with the the
radionuclides and so there was a
chemical reaction between the wheat and
the radiation that caused the explosion
the same person who figured that out
realized that 700 barrels were packed
with the same kitty litter and so far
only one of them has exploded
so while we were at whip we were
reminded of this strange contraption
which is the high level isolation unit
in london the royal free hospital in
london in england
which is used as an isolation facility
or a quarantine facility mostly for
hemorrhagic
diseases people who either have them or
are suspected to have been exposed to
them
and this is a place where there are also
extremely elaborate precautions uh to
maintain separation um that extend to
for example sealing the bodies of ebola
victims in a specially welded shut zinc
casket before they're allowed to be
removed from this
space
just to prevent
infection it also includes this strange
contraption that you'll see there and
that i'm about to explain and while we
were there and we were having all of
these elaborate precautions explained to
us um
the clinical director of the unit dr sir
mike jacob said you know this might seem
like overkill it's england you know when
are when are we gonna have to be dealing
with ebola um but he said listen the
principle here is not
risk the principle here is consequence
it's not a risk assessment thing it's
not how likely this is to happen it is
the consequence assessment how bad would
it be if it did happen and that's a
different calculus um that's abandoning
las vegas to the sands again some may
think that's a benefit but it is a
different calculus um and so that idea
of risk versus consequence is something
that came up again and again in
quarantine and is a really kind of
powerful way of shifting your calculus
but
another
takeaway from this
particular visit
is uh
the idea of quarantine as a designed
experience or rather that quarantine is
not a designed experience and needs to
be
so this is me inside a trexler unit and
the trexler unit has an amazing back
story that i wish i had time to tell you
about but
i don't but the way it works is that the
person who is
either suspected of having ebola or has
it
hops inside this tent and they're
probably not hopping if they actually
have it
and the doctors and nurses caring for
them
just kind of sort of insert themselves
into these suits built into the tent
wall um this is this is me inside it uh
immediately after the dr jacobs told me
that they had cleaned it using an
experimental decontamination procedure
after the last inhabitant left that was
a scottish nurse with ebola so um
there i am there he is and he as he
explains all he has to do and i i quote
him is imaginate himself into the wall
uh to provide care um
and so what what's interesting about
this
is the uk is completely unique in doing
isolation this way and and actually mike
jacobs told us
they get rid ridiculed for this uh
people laugh at them um everywhere else
in the world uh provides isolation uh
care for people with infectious diseases
using ppe
um
and this is uh this is jeff you might
not recognize him here on the left
in full ppe with uh our guide to
quarantine uh
who we met in venice who turned out to
be the chief scientific officer in
charge of italy's covet response later
but he had us he had jeff dr address up
in ppe to sort of show us
what this is like
it's extremely hot uh it's extremely
hard to put on and take off without the
risk of infection that's something that
people train
um for repeatedly and still get wrong um
and and you also look like an alien um
whereas in the trexler unit
um when you're uh imaginated into the
wall
you are not as hot you don't look like
an alien and anyone can do it so
non-trained experts can do it and also
family members can do it so this became
interesting to us um and apparently
interesting to others too
we were talking to
doctors who were caring for ebola
patients in
the drc in 2018 and they were telling us
we have a really hard time uh persuading
people to go into quarantine and
isolation because the culture
for so many of the people is is
don't be separate from your family
particularly when you're sick that's
just absolutely not um you know the
right thing to do and so people would
just resist quarantine and isolation
well congolese doctors saw the trexler
unit and adapted it for use in
in the congo these are these uh the
these sort of low budget versions of the
cube that have been extremely effective
and to us
that was um
kind of a reminder that quarantine can
be redesigned and that something that is
keeping you separate from your community
for your protection and for their
protection
uh
cannot still be designed in such a way
that it keeps you connected to your
community um
interestingly and we were fascinated to
see this at the start of the covet
pandemic this was adopted in in the u.s
too so there were some prototype units
being rolled out in boston
in june um that's a hug suit built into
the wall of
one of these cubes and what's
fascinating about this is
you know there was i you probably
remember there was this shortage of ppe
well
one of these units replaces
full sets of ppe
again allows family members to visit
um and everyone doesn't have to look
like an alien and it can pop up anywhere
so when the hospitals were getting
overwhelmed this was a viable sort of
way to provide care outside of award so
really interesting for us to be
imaginative and redesign quarantine as
an experience
um so one of the images that we opened
the book with is a description of how
quarantine facilities first kind of came
into the national consciousness at the
beginning of covid there was this really
extraordinary scene that happened up
outside seattle washington where the
local health authority had purchased an
econo lodge motel
because there was no place for for
quarantining they didn't have the
infrastructure or the architecture or
the facilities to do it and so they sent
a crew out wearing ppe
they stepped out of a van walked over to
the econolide sign and then just started
painting it black uh it was like a you
know a slayer video and so they just
gradually uh the sign that set is still
glowing econolodge i was just gradually
replaced by this matte black rectangle
like a pirate flag kind of hanging over
the street that just basically said the
previous function of this building has
been canceled this is now a quarantine
facility
um so quarantine it presents an
interesting infrastructural challenge
we've already talked about some of the
logistics of it how to get waste or how
to get infected people or potentially
infected people rather from one place to
another to another um you know how one
can interact with them if you're a
doctor or a family
but then finding enough place in an
enough space in a in a time of mass
quarantine is a huge architectural
challenge
um and so someone else that we met for
the book was uh the now former head of
the army corps of engineers
um which is the us agency who
effectively is put in charge of building
things of making making uh changing the
landscape building dams and levees and
hospitals and whatnot
and what was quite interesting was that
he pointed out some things about the
otherwise perceived aesthetic
limitations of the american landscape
the sort of cookie-cutter-ness aspect of
it the fact that hotel chains you know
uh if you when you drive out of a city
you'll see the same series of of the
three or four different hotels three or
four different gas stations three or
four different subdivisions that are all
designed and constructed by the same
company um this kind of similarity this
this j.g bellardian
identical nature of the american
landscape actually lends itself very
well to mass quarantine and so what he
was tasked with doing this the former
head todd semonite is his name the
former head of the army corps of
engineers
was to come up with a way to retrofit
the american landscape for quarantine
and so he did he came up with a a
a guide that allowed uh local experts
and contractors and uh uh
public health authorities to retrofit
hotel rooms uh dormitories convention
centers this is the javits convention
center in new york city that's been
turned into a site of quarantine purely
by introducing you know cubicle-like
walls and cots you know he found a way
uh general semonite to
uh trick air conditioning units in
motels so that they could actually
produce negative air pressure and not
you know
allow germs to spread from one room to
the next
and so what was so interesting about
that and there's many things as an
architecture writer that i'm drawn to
there um but is that you know we are in
a position that i think
uh
for the next quarantine the next
pandemic you know that i think that we
are going to be technically and or more
technically and architecturally prepared
for quarantine but we will not be
emotionally ready to experience it which
is the real challenge of how to deal
with quarantine next
and so one of the things this is this is
a challenge you could have seen coming
essentially because one of the things we
did while we were reporting the book as
we went to um
pandemic simulations and so these are
essentially like role playing exercises
where world leaders domestic leaders
gather and try to game out their
responses to a disease outbreak
one of the ones the the most recent ones
we went to before covet 19 was called
event 201
so named because the world health
organization deals with an average of
200 epidemic events each year and they
figured it was only a matter of time
before one of those had global pandemic
potential
as it happens event
201 which happened in october 2019
was simulating
a uh novel corona virus
and one of the participants was none
other than george gao
who is head of the chinese cdc and so i
think you can see how useful
role-playing a novel coronavirus in
october 2019 was to the global response
i just want to also say it came with a
plush toy of a corona virus so we we we
still have that we have yeah
um
so uh
the thing about these simulations is uh
you saw the same mistakes made again and
again and each time you know the the
organizers would write reports with
recommendations most of which echoed the
last report
um but one of the most sort of striking
features of them is that um
each time we were there people would say
ah okay so this is where we implement
quarantine and then they would move on
as if quarantine was a drug or a vaccine
not as if quarantine was a lived
experience that people have that has to
be implemented it has to be enforced it
has to be endured people have to go
somewhere and do something
and so that aspect of quarantine was
completely overlooked as a as a lived
experience and and this is where we
start to resonate with our um long short
that that started the evening because
the fact of the matter is quarantine is
boring
um not the book the book is
great um total page turner but
quarantine itself is extremely boring
and it always has been there are letters
from you know the priest in charge of
managing quarantine in 1600s genoa
saying what are these women i'm in
charge of supposed to do all day
um there are letters from 18th century
aristocrats saying i've written letters
to everyone i know i've tallied up all
my expense reports and now i'm going
slowly mad um
so
these these themes are uh you know and
then you have covert 19 where you know
the british public spent half their
waking hours watching netflix literally
calculated uh during during the first
lockdown so it's boring and and so
and everyone knows that so how to fix it
we spoke to a boredom researcher
for the book and she said well you know
boredom it's not really a thing it's
just a signal
that you're not engaged in what you're
doing and you're not finding it
meaningful
and then she told us about a study she
had done called the jerk study
and basically consists of
making people really bored she has them
watch a video of a rock for 20 minutes
um and then she gives them something
the option if they want of doing
something mean
so you can take money away from a person
or in this version of the experiment and
there was a
a worm killing device set up and you
could choose to kill the worms
and she said listen if people are bored
and you give them the option of
something bad to do they will do it
every time
similarly if you give them the option of
something good to do they will do that
and the takeaway from this is not that
people are terrible but
that if quarantine if people are going
to be on board and quarantine and they
are how can we give them something good
to do how can we redesign quarantine to
make it
a positive experience since we know this
is coming this is the lesson of history
quarantine is always boring
and you know the other the larger
picture there is that
quarantine should be a meaningful
experience and you are doing something
making a personal sacrifice for the
public good it just doesn't feel like
that so
how do we redesign re-demand it
reimagine it uh give it some experience
design um and that sounds frivolous but
it isn't and now is the moment to do it
because we are going to experience
quarantine again in our lifetimes and
when jeff and i used to talk about this
research back in like early 2019 and
2018 we used to tell people you are
going to experience quarantine in your
lifetimes now we say you are going to
experience quarantine again in your
lifetimes
but there's this tendency to want to
move on but
our point is now is the time with the
insights that we have from kovid19 to
ask what should quarantine look like in
the future
um so briefly the worms weren't actually
killed it was it was a fake worm killing
machine
and so the the ethics were
spoilers weren't quite as bad
um
well i just felt bad for the worms uh so
the the future of quarantine you know i
think as you can see from what we're
talking about it really doesn't require
a technical solution it requires more of
an emotional or even spiritual or
a narrative solution something that
gives quarantine meaning however you
find that in your own life but
nevertheless uh the technical perfection
of quarantine is something that many
many people are now trying to to figure
out as healthcare
data
and uh
smart home sort of technology all
combined into one massive edifice um and
so just briefly i wanted to talk about
how we look at the future of quarantine
towards the end of the book one of the
things that we come back to and that you
see here that we're looking at is
actually these companies that are moving
into
the quarantine space moving into a way
to try to make quarantine so that it can
be predictive it can be algorithmically
implemented
it can be more precise it can be
something where you know one single
individual out of thousands can be
chosen can be found maybe even
preemptively quarantined
to save the 999 other people
and the the the technical possibility of
that goal um without necessarily
thinking of the moral or ethical risks
or even the constitutional risks that
come with pursuing it
um in this case we're actually looking
at a patent diagram um the specifics are
not particularly important in terms of
the the slide but it was an actual
patent filed by amazon so that it's a
echo digital uh speaker could recognize
sounds of illness and depression in
people who were speaking or coughing
around it um so if you are coughing or
sniffling it might offer a uh a you
could purchase cough drops uh you could
subscribe to something on amazon if you
sounded depressed or lonely it would
offer maybe uh something from your
a previously viewed video selection that
might cheer you up again um the notion
that a private company would step into
those kinds of uh mental health
decisions uh public health decisions is
something that i think uh you know has
some relatively ominous overtones for
the future but what we see emerging i
think out of the assisted living
world for elder care
is i think the future of the domestic
environment and thus the future of
quarantine so you see a lot of assisted
living facilities getting technology
implemented and integrated into the
rooms themselves
using things like doppler radar for
telling if a body is moving through a
room and at what pace because if you
suddenly change uh gate dramatically
there might be a physical injury
involved
sensors in the floors that can tell if
someone has fallen over so that they can
send nursing staff in to rescue you
they can also tell if there's a gate
difference maybe you've had a stroke
cameras behind the mirrors that can see
skin tone so maybe you are having
cardiac issues or you have a fever
or some other kind of a bodily event has
happened to you but so this medical
diagnostic equipment
which which at the moment is just part
of you know taking care of the elderly
will undoubtedly
trickle down into everyday domestic
spaces in fact i'd be surprised if there
isn't a new uh development somewhere in
the san francisco bay area uh that is
experimenting with these kinds of things
you know for for people who who are not
yet elderly so to speak um but so what
happens with this and i think what the
risk is is that
um
if you already have a world which is the
world we live in where you know an
internet search giant has access to
things that we've been looking up you
know google tried something about
several years ago called google flu
trends that was looking at whether or
not you could tell you could find hot
spots for flu outbreaks in the united
states based on what thing what people
were searching for
um if that same company also you know
owns some of these other diagnostic
appliances that will live in the smart
homes of the future if they also control
your front door lock or if they own the
camera that you have at your front door
you're beginning to see the outlines of
a system that can say not unlock the
front door until you show proof of
vaccination or not let you for that
matter leave the leave your house unless
you're going to a doctor's appointment
and there is actually a car on the way
to pick you up um you have the
possibility of algorithmically uh
induced quarantine being
implemented by the buildings themselves
in a way that escapes many of the
constitutional or public health concerns
or even ways to push back against
quarantine that we haven't really gotten
into tonight but that we talk about in
the book a right of appeal that kind of
thing
another risk very briefly though is just
that there's a false promise in all of
this and i think it's that
if we give private corporations the
ability to make health care decisions
for us or for their algorithms to make
health care decisions for us
we're assuming that public health is
actually the goal of what they're doing
but of course a well populous a healthy
populace healthy customers are not
necessarily what they have in mind
and so you know it isn't necessarily the
the greatest thing for this business
market to suddenly help everyone get
over the illnesses that they're being
held in their homes for and i think that
that's one of the
certainly one of the moral risks of of
the future of quarantine the other thing
is this belief that big data and
algorithmic analysis will give us enough
information to make quarantines ever
more precise to turn this blunt medieval
instrument into something for the 21st
century that
hardly hurts at all um it sounds
compelling uh tech companies believe
they can do it
but
as weather forecasters have found you
can feed more data into the model you
can have sensors everywhere and you
still can't tell what the weather is
going to be like here in fort mason in a
month's time so there is a limit to what
can be modeled in fact the uh the
digital epidemiologist one of the ones
we spoke to for the book ended up on the
kovit 19 modeling team for the uk
government
and and told us really it's just a
matter of evaluating which is your least
worst option honestly that's what the
models do for you
um the other thing that uh this uh
digital technology
enabled quarantine seems to promise is
you know the the idea that we can slice
and dice quarantine um and and
politicians were
and i apologize for showing a picture of
cuomo
um but his polistarian mountain was
maybe his finest moment and uh and
politicians were quick to leap on that
to say well let's have these color-coded
tears and let's have these micro
restrictions where you can be with three
families if it's outside but only one
family inside and you can have people in
a support bubble and this was all sort
of calculated
and yet those kinds of quarantine
restrictions those kinds of restrictions
on mobility and interaction proved less
effective because the logic behind them
was so opaque and appeared not to be
even understood by the politicians who
are advocating them
let alone followed by them in most cases
and so that unfair and
unenforceable essentially kind of
precision quarantine actually
may well not be the solution
um and so with that i'm going to
bring us to a close by saying
it's
it's really uh it was really bizarre to
be finishing a book about quarantine
during covet 19 and lockdown but it was
actually more so frustrating um we uh
in the history of quarantine saw every
single mistake that happened during
covet 19 had happened before
and there's a natural urge to say well
when the pandemic's over can we move on
can we forget can we not learn
and uh
the
that's incred that's the wrong move we
need to redesign quarantine um not just
because we're going to experience it
again as i said but also because it is
shaping the world around us um and i
give just a a quick example here the
passport which is now the
piece of paper that regulates our
movement around the world its ancestor
is the health passport
which was developed first pioneered in
what is now italy in the uh 1500s as a
way of avoiding quarantine you would get
one of these documents and it would say
that you were coming from a place that
was healthy
and not diseased and that would allow
you to dodge quarantine well that has
hardened into
you know a piece of paper that
determines
exit and entry around the world and the
same thing is true we in the book we
trace national borders that are former
quarantine lines we trace bureaucracies
even the united nations itself
back to
uh disease control measures
you can see the start of this happening
now this is the alipay system in china
that is being used to
regulate movement um
that this kind of thing
it's a temporary thing
an emergency thing that starts happening
during pandemics and then hardens into
the new reality and so yes we live in a
world that is shaped by quarantine's
past and our future is being built from
today's lockdown as we speak
thank you
[Applause]
well thank you guys that was fantastic
and could not be more
appropriate of a topic um and i just
want to let you guys all know there are
signed books out in front
and they're going to hang around after q
a to inscribe them
if you so wish
um
i thought it was really interesting you
bringing up the waste isolation plan
that that same rift uh area is where the
clock site is about 60 miles south of
the whip uh site so it's going to
become our little isolation site for the
clock as well
um kind of keep it out of harm's way
anyway
um
i think
what was interesting i think obviously
about this quarantine that we're in is
that in some ways it was the least
boring quarantine in history right like
we had
we had access to world and most of the
world a lot of the world i guess had
access to world news
we could a lot of people could work from
home um in certain types of ways or at
least communicate from home
um
how do you think that that's a where do
you think that fits in the spectrum of
the history of quarantine
um i guess i'd say a couple things there
i mean it's it's it's
one of the things that really struck me
about
the lockdown for covid was how many
people were inspired to change their
lives precisely because they got to see
their life through a kind of intolerable
lens of of a groundhog day like
permanence you know this is the thing
the very things that people would have
said would have been you know say their
perfect sunday
you know that they're going to stay home
they're going to watch netflix they're
gonna you know just read books on the
couch when you're told that that's what
you have to do and that that's an
inescapable fate and that this is the
thing that you're going to be doing for
for you for you know another 12 months
suddenly your own everyday life becomes
intolerable and i think that that was
one of the things that inspired um so
many life changes you know we had people
that moved out of los angeles where we
where we live um marriages amongst our
friends fell apart uh relationships
broke up people quit their jobs they
moved to you know boise uh doing things
to just just get a change from los
angeles is my point um but so i think
that that was one one thing that was
that was quite interesting about it but
i think also
um in the history of quarantine i guess
the other thing i'd say is that
originally speaking 600 years ago
quarantine was actually a communal
experience so when we went into we
humanity went into quarantine
it would be with our neighbors and our
family and the the other crew members on
ships that we had arrived with uh whole
neighborhoods might go into quarantine
together churches would go into
quarantine together they'd go to the
lazaretto they would go to an external
facility and cycle through that facility
uh almost ritualistically and that ties
into that idea of uh
the religious overtones of quarantine
this was a period of cleansing you know
we're going to go through it together
and we're going to emerge a new
proven safe and go back to our everyday
life and so it's quite interesting that
now quarantine um is almost means
exactly the opposite of that it's this
atomized experience it's going off to be
alone it's you know sort of hiding off
in an apartment of our own so i think
that that's one of the interesting ways
i think that this kind of can be both
compared to and contrasted with the
history of quarantine
that's seriously and i think
you know germ theory was is relatively
new yet clearly people were
understanding this in some in some way
and you know and my understanding of the
of the massive pandemic in north america
when westerners first arrived was so
much it was so exacerbated by the fact
that when somebody got sick the family
would come around those people and then
of course get more and more people sick
but it does seem that in at least in
parts of history i mean what how what is
the earliest pandemic that we know about
it's it's certainly before germ theory
was
figured out by a lot absolutely and one
of the things we look at in the book is
why did quarantine emerge where and when
it did like who
you know because there's no if you if
you don't have germ theory there's no
scientific reason that you would think
that separation and isolation is the way
to go um and
it's
it emerged in we don't you know we
didn't talk about this in the in the
talk but it emerged in uh the adriatic
sea
when the black death first arrived in
europe at the time europe had had
centuries of freedom from
um epidemic disease that infectious
disease
and so this was sort of a novel
terrifying thing that had made its way
from
the east you know broadly speaking and
breached
europe with trade goods
and
one of the you know
merchants really just wanted to preserve
the source of their world wealth which
was trading with the east
while not all dying and so quarantine
was this idea that we could just sort of
park the ship outside on an island
initially you know just offshore um and
see if it was safe or not
because they could correlate the arrival
of trade goods with
um
with the outbreaks of the black death
and and the so there's this this idea of
observation there um you know these are
merchants uh who are watching the flow
of business there's also uh
an element of you know not you know in
some in some
regions if you would think that you know
a plague is a is a punishment from god
or a misalignment of the stars then
quarantine makes no sense you wouldn't
you know you wouldn't have a reason to
implement it you would instead pray or
or hope for the stars to realign
themselves um and then the other piece
is that this was part of the republic of
venice and it was
um not a democracy in the sense that we
know it today but there was an elected
leader and there was a sense of
public
and public responsibility
and responsibility for public health in
that leadership and i think
and people being answerable to the
community and that sense of public is
actually essential to public health um
and again is one of the reasons why
quarantine emerged where it did whereas
in the new world where there were far
fewer animals to be domesticated there
were fewer zoonotic diseases and then
and thus fewer
pandemics to be dealt with so there
there's a sort of ecological political
cultural religious logic to quarantine
emerging where and when it did
and essentially
i mean venice was kind of built as an
isolation uh effort right more of a
defensive one but it kind of probably
helped act as a quarantine zone as well
well yeah that's one of the things that
we mentioned in the book actually is
that venice you know even though
technically quarantine was invented in
what is now dubrovnik it was really
perfected in venice but precisely
because the geographic forum of venice
lends itself so well to isolation and
quarantine um you know and it's not a
coincidence that venice is also where
the first ghetto was was devised and
implemented where the jewish population
was required to live in a certain area
of venice that was actually sealed off
with gates where he had christian guard
station to make sure that they they
wouldn't come out at night and so you
know that's that's sort of a byproduct
of the geography itself when lending
itself to uh quarantine
i think one of the things that you guys
touched on in your talk and that became
painfully clear i think to all of us and
certainly did to me
in going through
a quarantine is that is how imperfect it
is
right like and i remember talking to the
scientists in biosphere 2 and they're
like well we still have ants that we
don't know where they came from you know
it's like they're trying to isolate so
heavily and you know as we were all
wiping down our groceries at the
beginning of this thing and you know
you'd still then you'd realize oh i just
brought that thing and i don't you know
it was just like it was all it's all
imperfect um at all levels i'm sure and
you know it's we have some of the
diseases that some of the worst diseases
that have escaped have have been from
labs have level four labs right so that
imperfection i think is the thing that
makes this so human and so you know the
whole thing is built of humans um and so
it's just not really good
how do we how do we wrestle with that
well so quarantine is always leaky and
in fact the um the head of the cdc's
division of global migration and
quarantine uh went back and when he
started in the job he wanted to abolish
quarantine get rid of it from the name
didn't think it was a useful tool
anymore you know it was the end of the
20th century at the time coming into the
21st century surely we could do better
than this medieval tool um and he went
back and analyzed uh outbreaks for which
there was actually good data which was
primarily the 1918 1919 flu and he
realized oh
quarantine does work and it works even
when it's leaky in fact sometimes the
leaky quarantine works better than a
quarantine that you're enforcing heavily
because then you don't actually know
where the escapees went
but
so the data shows that it does work and
the reason it works is because it's
working at a public scale
it's working and and marty cetron this
is the director of quarantine the cdc he
was actually the one who originally
coined the term that we all heard
this time last year of flattening the
curve
so it's working at the public scale it's
reducing transmission it's not
eliminating transmission it's not
eliminating risk and i think that's
what's so interesting about it is it is
flawed and it is leaky so it starts to
seem pointless because we want certainty
but as we said quarantine depends on
uncertainty and it involves uncertainty
and it is about reducing transmission
not eliminating it that feels incredibly
unsatisfactory but that
to me that's that's what makes it so
scientific science science is a process
of trying to get closer to certainty
rather than actually kind of arriving at
it i think that misperception um you
know
we all want certain certainty we don't
want to live with nuance and finding a
way to make us comfortable with nuance
and uncertainty and knowledge
progressing is the way to go
yeah well it's that's the nuclear waste
is like that too i remember i visited a
lot of nuclear waste sites around like
yucca mountain and and ankalo and europe
and and you know scientists are always
charged with making a hundred percent
safe facility and then someone asked
them the question how can you be sure in
a hundred thousand years that this is
safe and he's just like well we can't
it's
it's a it's a very interesting problem
and
just briefly along those lines what's
interesting too is that
many of the people that were actually
tasked to write about uh the waste
isolation pilot plant and look at the
risk of what's called advertent entry so
that's people that are deliberately
trying to get into whip um they're
basically just saying there is no way to
stop this you know it's not a burglary
proof vault if you're going to drill
into whip you can do it um and so
there's basically no way to just you
know to make people not do that but
there was a really interesting quote
from an individual who we put in the
book i can't remember it verbatim but
the paraphrase is basically if you look
at the history of uh
human uh facilities that have you know
been buried or put in the center of a
pyramid or a tomb uh that has been of
interest to archaeologists um when you
look at how humans deal with things that
have been hidden away or buried um you
know basically none of our nuclear waste
facilities have any chance of becoming
you know of actually fulfilling their
long-term promise and for somebody in
the nuclear waste industry to say that
it's a bit like okay so you know
you mentioned that whole project of how
to market and you know a lot of the
results of that if you look at the
markings that were on the outside of
king tut's tomb they you know they said
you know your family will become sick
for generations like it's basically all
the same things we mark a nuclear waste
site but it's nothing you know it
nothing makes you want to think there's
gold on the other side of that door more
than that they didn't have glowing cats
there yeah the glowing cats
sorry the other thing that i just
thought was so funny is that the
department of energy um in one of their
papers they actually bragged that they
they finally chose these giant uh
granite blocks and that's what they're
gonna carve their warning message into
um but they actually brag in one of
their uh uh white papers that that their
their rock is better than stonehenge
anyways it was pretty amazing nice yeah
i went to one of these conferences of
the geological repository
leaders and they all know that the right
answer is to not mark nuclear waste it's
the safest thing to do and but they all
know that is a politically impossible
answer for them to give so it's an
interesting problem
kevin kelly asks um so let's say
contagious viruses are going to be the
norm for urban humanity what do you
think our response is going to look like
in 50 years
the optimistic version or the
i mean i i do feel that um
we are going to leave this to um the
tech
industry and
we are going to
live in a world where
at the flick of a switch our own
individual movements will be restricted
using
whatever we are
whatever technology we have by then so i
feel like the trend that we are seeing
where private companies are moving into
it and we are increasingly living in um
censored environments
our entire body is monitored at all time
that trend will allow
either public health authorities or in
fact companies delegated to
execute on public health contracts to
kind of switch individuals into
lazaretto mode where your your movements
are restricted and those around those of
the people around you or not it's not
what i want to see happen but that's
what i think will happen
excellent yeah i think the
these are
among the types of events like
earthquakes and asteroid impacts um that
are 100 predicted
but you know not when but that they will
happen um but that humanity seems to be
not so good at remembering um you know
just a hundred years ago that the last
one that we had and how to prepare for
it uh mollystar asks um what part of
your research
surprised you the most
i mean it was
the planetary quarantine stuff was
pretty surprising to me
two parts of it one the fact that you
know nasa straight ahead goes and says
yes there's life on mars because we
brought it
um so clear planetary quarantine has
already failed and and second of all i
hadn't really realized the lengths to
which
um you know the cdc had said it would
refuse entry to the apollo astronauts um
if they weren't in quarantine and then
the
the fact that you know the plan for the
lunar receiving lab if an alien
replicating agent had been discovered
was literally to bury it and everyone in
it alive under
a mountain of rock and dirt
um
that that was a
that's just part of the apollo story you
don't usually hear that was surprising
yeah i'd say that there wasn't a lot of
like macro scale stuff that was too
surprising it was definitely the
granular details of the stories that
that really kind of struck struck me as
well i mean one one detail that
um i'm specifically mentioning it
precisely because it's not in the book
and i kick myself every time i i i say
it just because i wish we had included
it um you know i've mentioned you know
like the lowly fox that brings down
alexander's gates the kitty litter that
that almost blew up whip um we went to a
place in uh st paul minnesota where they
deal with very very pathogen virulent
pathogens that would attack the wheat
supply or other agricultural commodities
in the united states
they actually only use these or research
them in the winter months
because minnesota itself is considered
in in winter is considered a quarantine
barrier
and so you know if it were to escape
from the lab it would basically you know
freeze and die in the in the in the
extreme you know minnesota uh weather
which i also think is funny because i've
relatives in minnesota but it's so bleak
that uh you know it it's a it's a
quarantine site but um they were worried
that this place this facility that they
researched is actually too close to the
university athletic fields and they have
a very specific worry the worry is that
an over strong javelin thrower
will some summer throw the javelin too
ambitiously and it will actually go over
the the athletic fields and it will
pierce the side of this
pathogenic wheat research laboratory and
it's a greenhouse to yeah aka a
greenhouse yeah but um
and fuss you know the the great global
food apocalypse you know will be
unleashed by a a university of minnesota
javelin thrower
nice
um i i i have to say i was really
surprised to hear that
uh that there was a global pandemic uh
simulation in october of 2019 and the
head of china's uh you know cdc was
there and i'll never forget one of the
very first
news stories i saw on this was an aerial
shot of
like 65 excavators building a quarantine
facility in wuhan and going
whoa they're building a hospital in
three days
and it was like clearly they had a
different mental model than we did um
and and it was it was born out
and actually the chinese then when italy
started uh you know going through its
first coveted way
chinese health officials came to it you
know offer advice and their experience
and they suggested building these
centralized quarantine facilities so not
just isolation but quarantine if you had
been exposed if a family member
tested positive you should be rounded up
and put in a centralized quarantine
facility and that's what they built in
in wuhan and elsewhere in china and and
used and that's what they thought was
effective and the italians said well
thanks but that's not possible here um
when we spoke to todd semonite of the
army corps of engineers he said well
yeah that's what we did in the military
centralized quarantine yep we knew it
worked
but uh not possible for the american
public when we spoke to the director of
the cdc division of quarantine um you
know in october 2020 well into the into
the pandemic he said yeah we had these
debates it's a bit like the nuclear uh
repository folks so the best thing would
have been centralized quarantine but it
was politically unfeasible so it's a you
know in china politically unfeasible is
a different um calculus so
um and raphael from uh one of our live
streams um is asking um do you see
examples of quarantine like behavior in
other primates or other species i think
you mentioned beginning ants or insects
yeah so this is a fascinating and
emerging field of study um and it makes
sense because of course other species
are social and they incur you know
as well as the benefits of being social
they incur the risks of being social
which is infectious disease spread
and other species also build
architecture and so you know they've
been building architecture for longer
than us uh termites and and ants and so
on and so there are researchers starting
to look at well do these social species
and these architecture building species
do they quarantine
um and there is emerging evidence that
they do
reshape the design of their spaces to
restrict
interactions so they sacrifice some
efficiency in their food gathering
operations to
reduce the ease of transmission of
disease for example
also one one analogy i i loved is that
termites when they're when there's a uh
a contagious infection will eat their
young
and uh and the researcher was like well
think of that like school closures
because
kids are these vectors that are the most
likely to spread diseases and the
termites are just kind of taking care of
that we have school closures they have
eating they're young um so
there are also some uh species where the
uh
the
um costs of quarantine are not worth the
benefits so for example chimpanzees with
ebola if a female chimpanzee has ebola
she's more likely to be attacked on her
own
um than she
then
if a female chimpanzee is exposed to
ebola i should say she's more likely to
be intact on her own than
then get sick if she stays with the
group so they'll stay with the group um
so there's species that do isolate and
species that have sort of weighed the
costs and benefits and don't
interesting
um kevin kelly asks um who is actively
redesigning quarantine today and where
do you go to get a design
well i think that
although it would be fascinating if
there was like an amazon quarantine
division um i think that actually it's a
sort of a piecemeal gradual reinvention
of quarantine that is happening we see
it you know through some of the things
that we were discussing in terms of
elder care and assisted living that you
know those technologies are extremely
useful when it comes to quarantine
um or medical diagnosis uh more
generally um actually todd semonite the
former head of the army corps of
engineers pointed out that um some of
the solutions that he's pursuing are
really almost just like a home depot
reward shopper sort of paradise so that
the kinds of things you would buy if
you're doing home renovations
like the zip up dust barriers that you
put in your house if someone is doing
you know maybe they're polishing the
hardwood floors in one room over
those dust barriers can be repurposed
for medical isolation
air conditioning units can can do the
same thing
but so my point is that i think that
it's interesting actually that
quarantine um is being sort of piecemeal
redesigned in real time now by people
that are trying to figure out ways to
make home delivery services more
efficient
to maybe redesign
offices from
open plan to maybe going back to the
cubicle model
but i do think actually that there is a
obvious business model opening up that
would is going to be interesting to see
who steps into it um you know where
people do come up with ways to reinvent
quarantine to redesign domestic houses
so that they are better at allowing
isolation you know which is perfect for
moody teenagers but also people who
might have coveted 19 or covet 25 or
whatever it might be one of the most
interesting uh examples in the book of
someone who's redesigning quarantine was
chevron of all people um so the energy
giant um and they are uh
they're doing this and it's it's kind of
a long story so i'll tell the short
version um in order to be able to
extract the natural gas under this
pristine island off the coast of
australia they have to completely
quarantine this island um
from invasive species or you know any of
the normal things that have sort of
decimated
much of the rest of australia um rabbits
rats cockroaches all have to be kept off
this island um and in so doing they have
completely rethought what quarantine
looks like and one of the things that's
that's fascinating is they actually have
sort of gamified it in a way so they
worked with computer grain designers to
design something called quarantine hero
and that to me
there's you know there's much more to
say about what they're doing but that to
me was the sort of creativity
incentivizing quarantine making
quarantine rewarding fun
addictive i mean we
know how to design those kinds of
experiences but quarantine hasn't been
designed that way and
chevron is doing it because they are
they want access to natural gas but no
one's doing it for public health and i
wish they were
well and as a follow-on to that you know
there was some some of these
technological things that started coming
showing themselves in covid like the um
using cell phone aggregate cell phone
tracking data to see you know how well
people are actually isolating um
[Music]
you know i think you guys were speaking
about the dangers of some of these
technologies but i think was is that a
case of maybe gamification and aggregate
data being used well would you say
that's interesting i mean if it if it
could be translated into something that
made it rewarding and also made you feel
connected to the people that you were
protecting then yeah i mean data does
not have to be used for bad it's just
that
um or for ill it's just that
what is the incentive for corporations
to to
use it for good
and a question from
bash
have you seen quarantine influencing art
or art influencing quarantine
yeah i would say definitely i think one
thing that we noticed was how rich
quarantine is both narratively and
metaphorically and how much it pops up
certainly in literature but definitely
in film as well um you know
a good example might be you know in 2008
there was a horror movie that was just
called quarantine um you know which is
interesting because the you know the
word itself i think elicits fear and a
kind of uh
a strange it has an exotic outdated sort
of uh you know it's it's a it's a
threatening word so instantly you knew
this is a this was a horror film um but
you know we track some of the literary
uses of quarantine you know obviously
some good examples might be um you know
the mask of the red death is an edgar
allen poe short story that is really
kind of an allegorization of isolation
but not so much quarantine
but is about people trying to get away
from a disease who inadvertently lock
themselves in with it
you know going back to uh the de cameron
was it was a story of people avoiding
the plague in order to get away and
actually tell each other stories in in a
in a condition or a state of quarantine
um but so i definitely think that you
see that in uh
literature and film certainly um it
lends itself really well to metaphor and
narrative but i'd also say that you know
when we first got interested in
quarantine you know we actually we
curated an exhibition at a place called
storefront for an architecture in new
york city
and the idea was that we brought
together a whole team of
interdisciplinary people
architects photographers a graphic
novelist a writer a theatrical set
designer
and we had them come together and
brainstorm specifically around
quarantine what does quarantine mean in
your field and so it's very interesting
to see like for example with theatrical
set design what is a set design that
might
elicit quarantine or allow for
quarantine what does it mean to
quarantine performers as opposed to
perform quarantine metaphorically for
the audience um you know these were
questions that were
uh explored by that group and i think in
a really fruitful and exciting way
and i i'm just going to use this as an
excuse it's not really art but to talk
about my favorite quarantine literature
which is quarantine erotica um and there
was a sort of a boom of this during
covet 19.
coveted 69 was one of the titles
um but uh but it turns out that that too
has a precedent and in fact there was a
mini boom of quarantine romance stories
in the 1800s when um people steamships
and and railways started to make travel
international travel more feasible for
more people
and and so quarantine became this part
of traveling where strangers were thrown
together um
and you know
while
the truth was being revealed about
whether they were diseased or not they
could also uncover aspects of their
common humanity
and
and find true love and so uh
there there was a whole mini boom of
these quarantine uh love stories uh love
in the lazarette and so on um which are
really you can find them on google books
and they're terrible and really fun
right and in a way almost every zombie
movie is a story about
lack of quarantine or something right um
the i i like how you brought up the
health health passports thing that goes
so far so far back and how there's this
kind of weird backlash right now against
using
a document to prove that you're healthy
even though that's how this is
i didn't know that that was the actual
history of passports um but have you is
it has it been through history that
we've had these kind of resistances to
these documents and obviously there's
been poor uses of them
in by certain regimes
i mean there's definitely instances with
the health passports of
people faking them and also of
authorities refusing to honor them so
you might get one saying that you uh you
know you are uh coming from not a
diseased place and they might put you in
quarantine anyway so they've always been
sort of you know a a document is a sort
of a a contract is a is a
attempt to create trust and that has not
always been the case um in in some
later uh having a smallpox vaccination
scar became
these sort of bodily passport required
for movement between locations often and
again people were physically inspected
for that uh whether you resisted that or
not i think often dependent on whether
you had the power to resist it um but
definitely um you know there's a
i think
the u.s though particularly right now i
would say maybe is unique in the in the
level of resistance but i i do think you
know as
as much as i am willing to show my
vaccine card i think that it is right
that people are concerned that the
restrictions that are put upon us now
will
or might harden into future restrictions
without any conversation about them
because that is what has happened in the
past
and
um stephen hubbard actually asked this
question that i think is a good
follow-up to that which is you know
this the history and the the evaluation
and cost of proactive
uh forms of of quarantine and the you
know one of the things that came up that
i thought was interesting during this
time was when they were trying to figure
out where
hot spots were one of the things they
were doing is testing sewage lines like
coming out of dormitories and colleges
and then
then they would know where to start
testing but obviously these kind of
sensors can start getting built into
built into infrastructure of cities and
start finding diseases before
they they really
blow up the way they have um but i'd
love to hear what has have these kind of
things happened in history and do you
see them happening in the future
well i was just going to talk about
sentinel chickens very quickly yeah well
so i mean there are low-tech ways of
doing that too i'm one of one of my
favorite um examples is sentinel
chickens which are the
los angeles for example maintains a
flock of chickens outside the city um
and watches to see if they uh develop
west nile um virus and
and if so then that is a warning that
the mosquito with west nile virus has
made it to southern california and they
must respond so the this idea of the
sentinel is is you know can be low-tech
as well as
sort of sewage monitoring
well that's the chicken in the uh
in the
coal mine yeah
interesting
no i i love that i love the sentinel
chicken answer actually i mean i was
going to say actually i think through
history there aren't too many examples
that i can think of where
you know there was
uh you know someone almost like the the
the person that was meant to taste the
king's food before the king to see if it
was if there was poison in it like you
know where you would use someone to see
if they got the black death or that kind
of thing i don't or the black plague
or you know i don't really think that i
can think of too many examples of that
but that would be interesting my point
would be if there were like human
sentinels throughout plague history
and uh and to look into those examples
um
and andy asks um
have did you come
maybe i should ask first did you come
across histories of information
quarantine and how that plays into this
type of quarantine
well yeah it's funny um you know on one
level even though i know that our talk
went back and forth between quarantine
and isolation um it would be interesting
to look at whether or not it is literal
information quarantine in the sense that
you're waiting to see if this book or
this piece of information or this new
theological doctrine is dangerous and
you're you know you're waiting to see
what the effects may be before then
releasing it into the public or putting
it into isolation um but i definitely
think that metaphorically um you'll see
examples of you know the vatican's
banned books uh book burnings in the
20th century
you know censored or banned websites
today you know as a way of restricting
information and i think certainly church
authorities or authorities that are
invested strongly in narrative um you
know will prevent certain types of
information from entering into that
narrative because it might challenge the
main characters or the main
moral messages of the story being told
of a religion or of a folk tale and so i
think that information control on that
level is certainly
isolated but then i think you get into
an interesting conversation just about
um you know again the the difference
between the two terms of isolation and
quarantine i mean i do think even
moderated comments in a way are a sort
of information quarantine i mean
tonight's questions have
essentially gone through a quarantine
process
um but but for years i had a you know a
google alert for quarantine and the only
results you would get back were about my
email is trapped in quarantine
um on a you know an i.t forum thread you
know
it it then exploded during covet 19 it
just became completely useless but um
but it
you know that kind of that kind of
information quarantine that kind of
filtering process and uh
the the pause before something um goes
live quarantine mode for a website
that's that that's also a true
quarantine
indeed um so we're going to
coming to the last couple questions here
but um i
one thing that just came up to me as you
were talking beforehand about signing
this book contract in 2015 um what made
you do it in 2015 what was how did you
choose this topic
i mean i think i think a bunch of things
you know we actually originally
that the exhibition that i was just
describing um that was
uh we we started that in 2009 and then
in 2010 was the actual uh quarantine
exhibition um but i think that you know
one of the origins of our interest
you know
i i as an architecture writer you know
my background is really writing about
architecture design in cities um but we
were in sydney australia back in 2009
and we went on a picnic with some local
friends
and the picnic was actually near an old
building that used to be a quarantine
station it's now called q station and
it's a kind of spa hotel
um so there are a couple things that are
interesting there one is that you know
the same
geographic and spatial conditions that
made it good for quarantine because it
was out out of the city it was across
the bay it's on a peninsula it's within
sight of the sea so it's you know it's
easy to get there from ships
it's surrounded by verandas it's
windswept you know all the things that
made it very good for quarantine are
what make it now very good for luxury
tourism
um but also the question i think that we
at first had was you know
why
well why are people no longer
quarantined here why is quarantine not
happening where does quarantine occur um
is quarantine you know something that is
obsolete and part of the past and
something that we've moved past
and don't no longer need to do and so i
think that we began looking this at this
question somewhat embarrassingly as you
know what was quarantine um you know
what happened to it and i think that the
minute you start looking into it uh as
happened with us you start realizing
that quarantine it's not that it's this
niche thing that you can't find anywhere
in fact it's everywhere you know it's in
the food supply it's in
astronauts going back and forth to the
international space station it's in our
metaphors it's in our mythology
you know it is in our architectural
history it's a whole um you know
neighborhoods you know you can actually
still see it on maps today like there's
a quarantine
um
what is the name of the road in
baltimore that now has a landfill on it
quarantine road
but so you can even see it in the in the
names of rode the lazarettos and
quarantines and these things pop up and
so i guess it sort of became this thing
where we started pulling on the string
of quarantine um and we did that
exhibition and then a couple years went
by i worked on a different book project
and nikki has a different book project
and then just decided that we just
couldn't stop thinking about quarantine
we still kept seeing it everywhere and
we thought you know what we should
return to this and and actually write a
book that ironically was going to be
called the coming quarantine and and
there was not a book about quarantine
there were books about specific
pandemics and specific quarantines and
responses to those pandemics but there
was nothing that looked at quarantine
across the span of history and across
all of its different contexts and we
felt that it had this really interesting
and powerful logic to it
that you could only pull out by looking
at it at it
across all of those contexts and so we
wanted to do that
nice and what's uh what's next for you
next for me is the book that i was
supposed to be writing instead of the
quarantine
jeff referred to my book project i'm i'm
writing a book about refrigeration which
i spoke about at the interval um and
which will um it's moving very slowly
because things move slowly in the cold
but it will one day be finished
how about you jeff and uh i guess for me
a whole bunch of little things at the
moment uh so some short fiction uh i
have a grant for some archaeological
research looking at the future of
archaeology
and uh some film stuff in the works so
cool well thank you guys so much this
was fantastic and thank you all for
coming we really appreciate it thank you
for coming
[Applause]
thank you